what advice would you give to a young
person a day a high school student
a college undergraduate that's thinking
about
career
maybe advice not about just career but
about how to live a life they can be
proud of
you know we talked earlier about
intellectual honesty and to me that's
the first step of just saying
to the best of your ability who am i
and what i what what's important to me
and what do i want to do and accomplish
if you can start with that
and develop some sort of rules-based
philosophical here's what i'll
what i'll do what i won't do
and
that way
you can be flexible and pliable and
you're gonna need to be but if you if
you still have
a compass
that tells you
hey at least i know this is the path i'm
gonna take i i think that's very
important the rules you're referring to
the principles
that's kind of like uh underlying
integrity so knowing what lines you
don't cross on this path that's exactly
right because if you have those
absolutes
there are many decisions that come into
focus very quickly
right because hey i'm that's not for me
or hey i'm willing to do whatever it
takes
to do x y and z and it has to do with
the thing you were talking about
it's kind of interesting you mentioned
this earlier in the in the conversation
about slippery slope and that's how
often it happens
like how the the the
slipping into unethical behavior happens
it's the slippery slope of little
adjustments you put stuff off
and that that i found that to be uh
i've been fortunate to
to not have to encounter these moments
very much in my life but i still
encounter them
that's what integrity i think
looks like is in
as this
the slippery slope is happening those
little things
is um
without drama without
making a show of it
making a decision that stands behind
your principles and just walking away
yeah and besides the big ideas i'm going
to change the world i'm going to
innovate i'm going to do all those other
things
i also start if i'm giving any advice
which you know we can debate whether or
not you know i should be giving advice
but
just in terms of well let me start with
this are you a good friend
can you be counted on
do you do what you say you're going to
do yeah right
are you accountable to what you sign up
for and do you hold others accountable
right what what does all that look like
and then
i think it's
being as intellectually curious and
well-read as you can be we live in a
world that is designed to distract you
right and
being able to sit with your thoughts or
go on a walk and think deeply about
something and not just surface
area you text me i text you back and we
decide the fate of the world based on a
couple of text messages or something
you don't want to lose touch
i think with being well read
and understanding
and standing on great thinker shoulders
and
learning from uh from from those works
and then i also think that
you know there's there's resiliency and
then there's grit
and i i heard someone say one time that
those those are slightly different
and
you know i'm also i know that there are
all kinds of challenges in life right
that are tragic that are unfair
there's no question that's the world we
live in
but for me personally
to try as much as possible not to be in
the victim
mindset
because unfair things are going to
happen
and
you know we all want to live in an
idealistic
just world that that should be what we
aspire to
i'm i haven't seen that yet i haven't
experienced that yet but yet you still
have to function
uh in that world so
you know i i think that that resiliency
thing is very important
and then
putting yourself out there
right because if you play scared and
you're always afraid to fail
you know this is probably a dumb way to
get to the end of the podcast but
there are times especially when i'm out
west
uh i love the big sky out in you know
montana idaho places like that yeah when
you look up at night it's almost like
i've never seen anything like this
before because there's no
light pollution so to speak
and sometimes when i look up the most
daunting problems that i'm experiencing
i'm like those those things have been
there
for a billion years or whatever and
i'll be gone and it doesn't
you know the most famous person on earth
200 years ago
so it you know it's pretty fleeting
and uh so make sure you you have a good
journey and especially coming out of
covid
i think telling people that you care
about that you care about them and
maintaining and cultivating your
friendships and relationships and
they're not just transactional
right and and making sure that someday
when you're laying there you can say
yeah i was good family member i was
a good uh a good friend i was someone
that could be counted on i think all
those things go into the mix of
you know however you want to take the
journey
you